there now with an exclusive interview
reaction is former Trump campaign
associate he is at the very center of
tonight's breaking news the Phi's abuse
scandal Carter Paige great to see you
sir just to remind people when you are
with me last time you traveled to Russia
and other places and when your country
when you came back they often debriefed
you very often and you cooperated with
your FBI because you're a patriot
throughout my life and with the CIA and
other agencies and so they considered
you a friend I always thought they did
yeah yeah well you're at the heart of
all of this the quote media leak
strategy which was on April the 10th
2017 struck and Paige communicating with
each other then it leaks the next day
the 11th and the Washington Post
then struck is congratulating Paige for
a job well done with two derogatory
articles about you that's the FBI and
the DOJ coordinating against you to leak
in an ongoing investigation your
reaction you know Shawn Tom Finn I think
said it best on your show and you know
going back weeks it's not about me
they're just trying to get to the Trump
administration the Trump campaign this
is just a way of tearing down all the
great things that President Trump is
doing let's be honest here though I mean
this is about your name your reputation
your old life and it's an ongoing
investigation you just heard what Sarah
Carter said 302s released the unredacted
portions of the Pfizer released you are
going to be exonerated with exculpatory
evidence withheld let's assume Sarah's
right considering she hasn't been wrong
yet what would that mean to you well
Shawn I just remember six years ago
tonight my good friend Chris Stevens
lost its life in a very similar
situation are these people people in
Washington you know there's no concern
about his safety and they're very much
worried about their narrative for the
media that's the focus it's not has
nothing to do with safety they're just
focused on their own spin for their own
personal gratification systemic culture
immediately
by high-ranking officials at the FBI and
DOJ related to ongoing investigations
that's what we're talking about it and
you're in the center of it you know my
mother was a prison guard
my dad was Family Court probation I had
more people in the NYPD the to two
people we refer to as daddy we're FBI
guys we're not talking about the FBI I'm
talking about a few people in the FBI
and the DOJ that abused their power and
basically used you as the single person
to go out there to get the president but
you have any doubt they're trying to get
the president now oh there's no doubt
whatsoever
what are you used when you spoke to
these people now interestingly you
haven't been indicted
of course not they talking to you
anymore I haven't talked about anyone
from the US government this year other
than the people in the DOJ where I was
you know I had my case against the US
government but and they keep you know
similar to the FISA Court Southern
District of New York keeps giving these
false testimonies to about you about you
know I have a case against the US
government and you know the fake news
probably lawsuits that your movie
absolutely you don't even want any money
you told me I $1 just you know nominal I
didn't say any lawyers with $1 I don't
know anybody I want to fix this terrible
thing that's happened to our country you
know this is just on principle but there
it's just so corrupt right now so tell
me if this is wrong with the FBI and the
DOJ we learned through these text
messages we're colluding to leak what a
phony Russian lies about you and then
the same DOJ hires Muller to investigate
it but the DOJ is working with the FBI
leaking it and then we find out through
Bruce or and Christopher Steele's
contacts
Christopher steel is saying did you get
my info to this your friends and the
Special Counsel tell me what's wrong
with that picture
well Shawn look I have you know dozens
of lawyers that I'm up against in DOJ
and that's on the Civil Division it's
been you know told friends at the
Washington Post New York Times that I
talked they were apologize to you for
taking leaks that are unverified
absolutely not no and you know a lot of
page 836 in the bottom right hand corner
nobody will find it
hopefully they start fixing this a
little bit showing you to sue them well
it's just like the first the fake Intel
report by clapper Comey Brennan On
January 6 2017 two weeks before the
inauguration it was split into two
themes one is the hacking the other is
government propaganda I'm doing I have a
legal action right now on the government
propaganda we'll see about that
now get this information that we want to
Declassified and and unredacted are you
convinced this exculpatory evidence they
withheld do you know that there's
exculpatory evidence the more
information that comes out it's just
gonna keep showing how ridiculous this
whole thing you think when you look at
the players steal or struck Paige McCain
do you think that was the insurance
policy
definitely seems like it all right
good look preciate sorry you lied about